uh welcome everybody to the next
presentation in the microsoft research
summit 2021
my name is drago mirada from yale
university department of computer
science and today i'm going to be
talking about some recent projects in
our lab on closing the loop in natural
language interfaces to relational
databases and i'll be talking in
particular about our work on parsing
dialogue and generation
so as you know a lot of the natural
language interfaces that are correct in
existence deal with unstructured text
such as images and videos and web pages
here we are focusing mostly on the items
in this purple box which is databases
knowledge graphs and tables from
wikipedia
so
while we would ideally want to be able
to build systems that understand human
language we still have to convert those
natural language questions into sql
queries for example select quantity from
product where name is hoverboard x10
obviously the users of the system don't
understand sequence so we still want to
be able to allow them to ask their
questions in natural language like for
example how many hoverboards are left in
stock and then our system needs to
convert those into sql queries
so today i'm going to talk about three
recent contributions to this project one
is about understanding the user better
this involves semantic parsing and text
to sql then understanding the data in
the tables by doing pre-training of
tables and finally responding to the
user in the form of answering questions
structure to text natural language
generation and summarization
so to give an idea uh if you have a
natural language like a question like
this one here
there are certain words in it that
trigger different components of the
matching system in different ways
so the four ways are european and
australian open are shown in red those
correspond to actual values in the table
the text in green corresponds to column
names or attributes the text in blue
corresponds to table names and finally
the text in purple corresponds to logic
snippets which have to infer some
information that was not explicitly set
in the table
so our first contribution to this
project was a data set called spider
which was the first data set for text to
sequel generation that has multiple
tables
joined with foreign keys
also different sql patterns for example
min and max aggregate comments um so
aggregate commands and also nested
queries
so it has 10 000 questions 6 000 unique
sql queries and 200 databases from 138
domains the only existing data set
before that was wiki sql from salesforce
and the difference between the two is
that wiki sequel was only about single
tables that didn't have any of those
complicated
uh additions so spider was built by
students in our lab and it took an
enormous amount of time
to build it and to clean it and to
verify all the data points
so the data here is divided into three
cut into four categories simple queries
medium hard and extra hard queries
so we have a leaderboard for performance
on the spyder data set as you can see we
went from a very low baseline
performance three years ago when this
project started so something in the
order of 10 to 18
points on the dev test and now most
recently we've been getting very high
performance submissions most recently
from acl21 by a group from
shanghai jiao tong university and ai
speech as you can see we have a huge
improvement in performance over slightly
over three years the second data set
that we created for this project is
called spark which is an extension of
spider to dialogue
as you can see here we have the user
interacting with the database and the
corresponding sql statements
there is also leaderboard where the best
performing system is a combination of
yale microsoft research and pace penn
state university that uses rat sql and
score
the third data set that we created is
called call sql and this is about dialog
state tracking using sql sql so here we
have the different dialog states and the
corresponding sql statements so again
this is a data set that people use to
evaluate their systems and as of the
time of this presentation the best
performance is again from the yale slash
msr slash penn state university team
okay now i'm going to switch to the
second part of this presentation how we
pre-train a language model from tables
i mean everybody knows that current
language models such as bert and roberta
achieve extremely high performance on
different question answering and other
natural language processing data sets
however they're only trained on text
such as wikipedia articles and books
now if you remember this example
in order to get high performance on
tables we need to do some additional
things which cannot be inferred from
plain text alone so this is encoding the
table content
jointly understanding the questions and
the tables and then figure out how to
use compositionality and logic to put
everything together
so one of the first ideas that we had
since we don't have a very large amount
of training data was to use data
augmentation in the same way that this
has been used in the past more notably
by gian liang and some other more recent
papers so in that case what they do is
they look at some examples on the
training set then they induce a
synchronous context for grammar which is
then used to generate some additional
examples from the same distribution
so this approach works pretty well in
certain cases but it turns out that it
doesn't work well in the tasks that we
are considering so we did an experiment
where we compared the performance of
systems with and without such synthetic
training data
on five different data sets so spider
spark and cosecal and also different
multi-walls data sets such as trade and
some bt
as you can see comparing the blue bar
and the red bar not only doesn't
performance improve when you add
the synthetic training data but in many
cases it actually falls down
and in bottom line is that we cannot use
this data set to improve the training
process
so instead what we're doing is slightly
different we're building a system that
has a compositional inductive bias that
is specifically designed for tables so
in order to do this we have first again
annotated text to sql examples we have a
synchronous contextual grammar that is
inferred automatically and then we use
this grammar to generate the sequence
examples and then we use this on some
sample tables so this is similar to what
people have done in the past with data
augmentation using converse now in
addition to this we have an additional
component which uses roberta as the
language model
so here's how this works in the first
stage we convert the sentences i'm sorry
the sql statements into
uh different semantic representations
for the different uh words and then we
train this using 475 000 synthetic text
to sql examples so this gives us uh an
objective function that we call semantic
prediction loss
now in addition to this prediction laws
we use another objective measure which
is called
mast language modeling just like in
other uh retrain language models and
then when we combine those two together
we get performance that actually
improves on the state of the art
so in order to evaluate this approach we
use four different
evaluation data sets two of them are
fully supervised and two are weakly
supervised in the fully supervised
semantic parsing tasks we have examples
of both the input sentence and the
output sql statement in the weekly
supervised examples we have sentences
and the answers but we don't have the
actual sql statement that we want to
learn so we have to treat it as a latent
variable
so now i'm going to show the performance
of the system on different data sets so
first of all we are comparing state of
the art system in
on the spyder data set which at the time
of this paper was rat sql as you can see
we have a performance in the high sixty
percent
using rat sql but then if we add our two
uh metrics for improving the performance
we get an improvement of about three
point seven to four percentage points
now i'm going to show you four other
experiments with this data set so first
one is on fully supervised wiki sql in
this case we did two experiments in the
first one we are comparing our system
with both objective functions against
the state of the art and we get some
nice improvements of around 1.6 percent
now what's more interesting is that if
we limit ourselves to a random sample of
10k examples then our performance
improvement over roberto large is even
better so the order of 2.7 to 3 percent
so this is this bottom picture here the
second evaluation is on wiki table
questions we see a very similar pattern
we get state-of-the-art performance by
combining our
system with grappa
and then we also do an experiment with
10 percent of the training data and we
get an even better improvement of 3.9
percent on the test set over roberta the
third evaluation is on weekly supervised
wiki sql as you can see we again have a
nice improvement in performance over the
state of the art
okay now let's move on to the next part
of this process we want to be able to
generate sentences that are grammatical
and faithful and fluent based on the
results of the sql query so let's look
at an example here we have a list of
table
a table of cars different makes and
models and also their
fuel efficiency
suppose now that we have a question that
says which cars get more than 100 miles
per gallon
the corresponding sql statement is
select name year powertrain highway from
vehicles where highways greater than 100
this gives us
four different results
the best performing car here is the
chevrolet spark ev which gets 109 miles
per gallon now suppose that we want to
convey this result to the user
so for example we want to build a
sentence from this last record here that
says that the 2013 nissan leaf electric
vehicle gets 102 miles per gallon
so in order to do this we have to
pre-train a system that can generate
text from structured data
so in order to do this
we built a data set that is called dart
which starts from tables when we keep
table wikipedia tables
and then we build a taxonomy
like the one that you can see here that
tells us which attributes are related to
which other attributes so in this
particular case we can see that
capacity is a property of stadium open
is also property of stadium stadium is a
property of team ct is a property of
team and in addition to this we can also
incorporate the table context and also
the table title itself
then we select the subtree from this
ontology and we build rdf triples that
contain information from the table so
here we have two examples in the first
one we say that the amsterdam admirals
is a team that plays on olympic stadium
and then we have another triple that
says that olympic stadium was built in
1928.
so this is the input plus the taxonomy
and the output is the sentences that are
generated from it so in our data set we
created a large number of what we call
darts which are the training samples in
this particular case we have two
examples one with two triples and one
with six triples
so we did some experiments uh using dart
with the best performance that we got on
all the different relevant evaluation
metrics was using t5 large which
outperformed every other system
and we also did an experiment on web
energy 2017 which is a standard
structured data to text
data set and in this case again it turns
out that using t5 large augmented by
dart gives us the best performance now
the next thing that we're doing as part
of this project is to build the question
answering data set over tables so in
this data set which we call feta qa we
start with a table and a natural
language question that corresponds to a
certain area of the table and then we
have
crowd workers produce the answers in the
form of actual sentences so in this case
the question refers to the title of the
table also to two of the different
attributes and then we want to be able
to compare the different records and do
some additional logical transformations
for example averages and means and maxes
so this data set is different from
previous question answering data sets
because for the first time we have an
answer format that is free form text
from wikipedia tables previously there
were data sets that do one or the other
either you can have free form text from
some other data sets or you can have
wikipedia tables but with short form
just factual answers and not full text
now the next thing that we want to do
which is something that we started
working on a few months ago is to
summarize tables and summarization in
this context can be done in two
different ways you can either summarize
the results from the query or you can
summarize the entire table so in this
particular case what we want to do is
not just to generate a sentence like the
one that i showed you earlier but to be
able to summarize the entire result
table and say that we have four vehicles
that get more than 100 miles per gallon
and then possibly enumerate them or
point to them in the table
so for this project we've been
collecting summaries of tables using uh
crowdsourcing interface so those are
some of the examples from each of the
tables we have multiple summaries
and then we also have an interface where
we show the users the structure of the
table the data in the table and also the
different summaries and we ask the users
to evaluate
the quality of those summaries
okay so now i'm going to wrap up as i
showed you in this presentation we have
a very active research project on
table to text interfaces and also on
semantic parsing
the main contributions have been posted
in the main conferences in the last few
years so first the contributions on the
semantic parsing site then on
pre-training for tables and then finally
your generation from tables
so let me thank you for your attention
and i would like to give credit in
particular to tao you who just finished
his phdl and moved to the university of
hong kong and also to all the other
co-workers for this project
thank you again and bye